wir haben dienstag den 24 april 2018 17
uhr 24 wie vielleicht einige wissen ist
der 24 april meinen geburtstag das heißt
ich habe heute geburtstag bin sozusagen
heute 21 jahre alt geworden und ich
haben ja mitternacht also als dieses
neue lebensjahr für mich begonnen hat
gedanken gemacht was möchte ich in
diesem lebensjahr und eine sache ist mir
sofort ein gefallen und zwar möchte ich
nicht dass es mit meinem youtube kanal
und mit mit euch somit mit meinem ganzen
internet leben so weiter geht wie bis
jetzt wie ihr vielleicht mitbekommen
blieb sie in den letzten monaten auch
meinen kanälen muss man schon sagen
nicht wirklich rund sorgt ich hab echt
lange keine videos gemacht ich habe
glaube ich in den letzten zwei monaten
zwei videos gemacht und ihr könnt euch
gar nicht vorstellen die unzufrieden
nicht damit bin und ich wollte heute
einfach mal ein bisschen darüber reden
warum es so ist und keine ahnung so ich
habe dieses gespräch so mit mir selbst
auch gar nicht so wirklich gesucht
in den letzten monaten und ja heute ist
es dadurch dafür eine 2 weil ich weiß
ich will was ändern und ich will euch
wieder mehr zum teil von meinem leben
machen es wird wieder mehr interagieren
mit euch sondern eine sache die mir ist
auch kraft gezeigt hat ich habe wirklich
wirklich monatelang jetzt so gut wie
keine videos gemacht sondern geht man an
seinem geburtstag auf twitter und hat
super viele leute die haben einfach
gratulieren die liebe nachrichten
schreiben und auch verständnis zeigen
dafür dass man solange keine videos
gemacht hat obwohl man keinen grund
angeführt hat so die einfach sagen okay
wir mögen ich gerne und das auch obwohl
ich jetzt nicht in den letzten tagen und
wochen so bei ihnen im leben rum
gegeistert bin mit irgendwelchen videos
ist wenn ich schon echt cool und es war
nicht sehr zu schätzen aber ja kommen
wir dazu warum ich keine videos gemacht
habe ich habe vor geraumer zeit
angefangen zu studieren das war so der
der große wandel sage ich mal in meinem
leben der stadt gefunden hat und so die
größte veränderung deshalb führe ich das
jetzt einfach mal als erstes an so was
für ein studium an sich hat man lernt
neue leute kennen man ist in der neuen
stadt ich habe jetzt schon länger in
köln gewohnt aber ich hab' köln erst
richtig kennen gelernt und
logischerweise hat man auch mehr zu tun
als man
als vollzeit in anführungszeichen
youtuber so hat aber ist der grund dass
ich keine youtube videos gemacht habe
die universität 9 beziehungsweise auf
keinen fall gänzlich weil es wäre
einfach falsch zu behaupten so ich hätte
so viel stress so management studiengang
ist cool ich fühle mich da wohl aber es
ist nicht so anstrengend oder
zeitintensiv dass sie keine videos
machen könnte daran liegt es also nicht
so viele leute aber immer geschrieben
wenn andere gefragt haben unternimmt
haus von mir oder so waren auch der
keine videos und den heutigen antwort
uni stress oder so
das habe ich zum teil für mich als
ausrede gesucht aber das ist nicht der
grund wenn es nicht das ist was war es
dann also was was könnte noch schuld
daran tragen dass ich so nicht
entwickelt habe
da gibt es natürlich die eine sache mit
f ich glaube viele von euch teilen das
problem auch und wissen wie es mir
dahingehend geht drehen natürlich von
vorteil sein okay das ist natürlich
kleiner spaß am rande aber ich habe auch
wirklich ziemlich viel ford bank ist
also verteilt ist es nicht uni ist es
nicht es gibt da noch so einen anderen
faktor der sich eine große rolle spielt
und zwar nenne ich das ganze jetzt
einfach mal faulheit womit jetzt aber
nicht gemeint ist dass sie einfach keine
lust hat videos zu machen sondern es war
so eine kombination von so einer
kreativen blog abel also dass mir
wirklich nicht das halte ich nämlich die
meiste zeit so ganz natürlich solcher
irgendwie gechillt und danach sofort das
könntest du als video idee machen und
das war dann auch immer die coolsten
videos die mir am meisten spaß gemacht
habt ihr euch am meisten gefallen haben
und die sind wir eigentlich immer sagt
einfach einen kopf bekommen und dann hab
ich jetzt aufgenommen so da hatte ich
wirklich so eine blockade und wie hat
dich ist es ausgeblieben dass ich so
meine guten ideen sage ich mal hatte
dann habe ich aber auch nichts dagegen
unternommen und habe mich nicht
hingesetzt
mich inspirieren lassen und irgendwie
mehr coole sachen überlegt sondern ich
habe das einfach so hingenommen und habe
sagen wir mal zwei wochen lang ein video
gemacht sondern da ist so der die wurzel
des bösen sag ich mal so die ursprung
alles
ich war zwei wochen inaktiv habe dann
mal wieder ein video hochgeladen und da
hab ich ja mal wieder eine coole idee
gehabt und das hat aber irgendwie so
diese ideen bei mir haben irgendwie so
mit der zeit abgenommen und ich wusste
irgendwie nicht mehr so was ich machen
soll und anstatt wirklich mich da
hinzusetzen und zu sagen okay du machst
was dagegen überlegt jetzt was du für
ein video machen kannst habe ich mich so
davon wirklich runterziehen lassen und
habe keine ahnung waren so nah so eine
abwärtsspirale und habe mir einfach
keine gedanken gemacht was ich machen
kann sondern hat mich hinsetzen p heute
macht es kein video am nächsten tag
wieder das gleiche
und plötzlich sitze ich hier und es ist
echt eine lange zeit vergangen in der
ich eigentlich nicht viel gemacht habe
und das fachlich richtig arbeit das
macht mich wirklich richtig wütend und
unzufrieden mit mir selbst weil ich will
das gar nicht so ich finde das
unglaublich geil so den welche die
position in der ich bin und ich weiß
dass kraft zu schätzen dass so viele
leute interesse an mir an meinem leben
haben und mir auch dinge ermöglichen so
die einfach nicht normal sind und ja ich
habe einfach so wenig wertschätzung
dafür gezeigt indem ich mich keine
ahnung einfach so der der faul oder
vielmehr so dieser dieser abwärtsspirale
nicht entgegengesetzt habe aber ja leute
ich habe jetzt echt gedanken gemacht ich
glaube es ist so eine kombination aus
die ding wird versteht mich nicht falsch
ich war jetzt nicht depressiv oder total
unzufrieden mit meinem leben ich hatte
trotzdem eine sehr schöne zeit in den
letzten monaten habe einfach mit mit
vielen neuen freunden und jana natürlich
auch mein leben gelebt und hatte auch
wirklich wirklich spaß aber es gab
einfach diese eine sache im hintergrund
die mich wirklich der konstant runter
gezogen hat so ein bisschen oder mich
wieder so ein bisschen auf den boden
geholt hat mir gesagt hat also irgendwie
was machst du da eigentlich ja das geht
auch noch eine weitere sache mit meiner
wohnung
feststellen dass ich nicht bei mir bin
falls ihr euch erinnert sondern alle
weil sebastian und darüber werde ich
sicherlich auch noch mal reden das kann
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt aber noch nicht
gemerkt schon vielleicht in welche
richtung das gehen könnte das ist
natürlich auch ein großer faktor der
mich sehr abgefragt hat aber all diese
sachen zusammen genommen und ungerührt
ergeben so den grund weshalb ich keine
videos gemacht habe was ich weiß ich
weiß dass es auf jeden fall nicht so
weitergehen sollte und deshalb habe ich
mir planen gemacht war sie zu meinem
neuen lebensjahr ab jetzt schon videos
aufgenommen die für euch in den nächsten
tagen kommen werden und bin wirklich ja
motiviert und bereit wieder zu euch zu
finden und zu dem ganzen lifestyle
wieder so zu finden
stories zu machen sodass sich auch
irgendwie kanal fast nie gemacht habe
und so habe ich einfach unfassbar bock
drauf jetzt wieder deshalb leute wenn
ihr mich begleiten wollte und wieder am
start sein wollt dann seid es wirklich
ich würde mich riesig darüber freuen
ich bin sowieso schon kraft dankbar dass
so viele von euch einfach so eine so
eine hohe toleranz aufweisen und nicht
rum beleidigen weil keine videos kommt
zu einem großen teil sind leute die mich
weiterhin unterstützen die bilder von
mir bearbeiten auf ihren posten die mir
schreiben nachrichten senden und einfach
so einen großen ganzen einfach echt ne
coole unterstützung sind ihr sollt
wissen ich weiß es sehr zu schätzen und
jetzt würde ich sagen genug gelagert das
nächste video wird normal ist und dann
geht es jetzt wieder los ab ins neue
lebens und youtube